einige experten sprechen ja ebenfalls
von bürgerkrieg der bürgermeister von
eindhoven hat gesagt das was auf der
straße passiert das ist so was wie der
mittelfinger für all die die sich gerade
solidarisch an die korona regeln halten
das sind der krasse worte die da benutzt
werden also wie dicht steht man
tatsächlich vor so einer art bürgerkrieg
dort in den niederlanden also die
sozialen medien rufen in den sozialen
medien rufen natürlich viele leute auch
zu plünderungen das ist ja das was ihr
gerade auch nochmal geschildert habe den
eindruck dass heute mittag wirklich
dabei was die polizei aufgezogen
um plünderungen zu verhindern ich gehe
davon aus dass das jetzt gegen abend
nochmal noch einmal verstärkt wird es
kommen immer wieder immer wieder auch
jugendlicher schwarz gekleidet hier
vorbei und ich denke
die niederlande haben tatsächlich angst
dass sie irgendwie was passieren kann
und ja man kann eigentlich nur hoffen
dass die polizei dass hier im griff hat
und anders als in deutschland ist es zum
beispiel in den niederlanden so dass die
bürgermeister auch der erste polizist
sind ähnlich wie das in den landkreisen
ist wenn der landrat der polizeibehörde
vorsteht
hier ist das auch so und die vereinigung
der bürgermeister haben heute nochmal
dazu aufgerufen sämtliche demonstration
was die korona regeln betrifft wirklich
im keim zu ersticken dass sie gar nicht
erst stattfinden können und hat auch
noch mal die bürger der einzelnen städte
aufgerufen sich solidarisch zu erklären
zusammenzuhalten nämlich nur so könne
man zusammen dass corona virus eindämmen
und tatsächlich im abendkleid von 21 bis
34 wirklich zu hause zu bleiben damit
möglichst schnell alle wieder auf die
straße können weil das muss man hier
wirklich sagen das hat in niederlangen
sehr erschütternd komplett alle
zeitungen waren heute davon durch voll
auch da wurde vom bürgerkrieg gesprochen
und man muss wirklich sagen dass die
polizei und die ordnungsbehörden hier
von dieser kommen danach tatsächlich
angst haben